one how are you it's so nice to meet you
it's real quick before we get histories
you're gonna go in the studio and do it
again what's the plan so I'll probably
know in the next there's okay I'm so
glad we're here
how you doing good what do you guys in
town for love it where where is that on
Bronx yeah hey no boy great I've been
giving you so much you love no I know
you don't even know better than you know
in I I did something real crazy for you
I was with the other day they're about
to roll out some [ __ ] fresh new [ __ ]
and they're like we really need somebody
like we really need somebody who like
and I was like pull up this account and
they real I'm doing some real funds like
obviously the stuff I bet you guys can
see but the behind the scenes stuff I'm
up to for you is really cool hopefully
some will come through
you're welcome so what's going on looks
like what's a what's important what's
important is I can I help like I really
believe I love the empowerment constant
like I love what you're doing like
settling the score but boys in the past
like I really like what you're doing
with the music but more importantly I
genuinely believe so Boyd's got his
version of an ear I almost feel like
we're ahead you got one year and I got a
different year and when we put both of
our ears go that's when we go
I really think you're part of a movement
that's gonna be really relevant over the
next five to seven years and I'd love to
you know I'd love to help I don't know
what you guys think you need help with
or what's been going on
I'm really where I think my strengths
place my fingers like performance like
my music I put it like I think you
should put your you know who's similar
me yeah I'm so good at keynotes that's
why I do that and everything feeds off
that I think you should perform for
[ __ ] free every day that's how you
killed me that you had a film person
like I do I would tell you to [ __ ] do
[ __ ] for free cuz I think you're so good
that the more of that [ __ ] that happens
actually I have a good idea for you guys
you should do a free pop-up show that
nobody knows about that's 48 hours in
advance you just start pushing on social
argument love random rant don't take on
any cost find somebody that needs people
to show up or do it we're doing ghetto
and do it like in the middle of the park
until they kick you out something that
just catches people's attention I told a
bookie to do that and he did it and it
[ __ ] wet it really worked
I'm so good like I mean I haven't even
seen it but I could see it through video
you could taste the energy through the
videos you love it right right you were
like theater II kind of like right you
need to first so what so how are you
thinking about that
can she get her to open up on there
that's the key right you know regionally
at first just because what about with
all the female empowerment like what
about pumpers an or like that whole kind
of punk rap thing she would kill that
world yeah it's true it's just everybody
wants open for them like sense what's
killing they would be great together
oh is that that from the email that I
knew that that RCA thread that was going
on or do you just go randomly on your
own ship I wouldn't randomly to Richie
Richie basically why bro she changes
phone number his candles he changes his
number like doing [ __ ] with you and
doing Boehner sports all these guys are
changing a number every [ __ ] week I'm
getting tired of it I'm like I'm not
gonna communicate to anybody no one yeah
oh my god but no one of the coolest
things is that uh she produces our own
music right and so that's crazy she's
actually something that don't like Billy
no one knows it but I don't want to be
like
[Music]
like it really is like it'd be worse if
I didn't know you were producing your
own stuff I would try to find out who
you should you should you should you
know 100% should I got idea why don't we
send somebody likes at from 137 p.m. we
wanted you so even though it's a mens
brand we want to do some female [ __ ]
I've been wanting to do this thing
called 24 hours with like what if we
just spent and I mean like in her house
like let's say Seth was doing it let's
say she went home at like midnight from
the studio I just slept from midnight to
7:00 a.m. like he would literally I'm
gonna be weird but like she'd after like
I mean it I want to make that's how I'm
doing it like he would like go to sleep
on the couch and put the camera down
it'll be like like you know a time-lapse
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
like I'm gonna show every hour of being
with a person for 24 hours
we could do it 24 hours for young baby
tape
he's a Barack gonna steal one of your
Susie's so how can I help from your
perspective you have a lot of context on
me yes into the goal of ours to further
motivate and inspire us she killed it
off and so all this really visually
speak to one Joyce's as a project yeah
you can hear the sound without a picture
on something so you we have this site
coming out called 137 p.m. it comes out
next week
Boyd's about to get back into this
hip-hop at lunch days we're about to
literally he's gonna write an article
like who's next all the time that's why
the gonna be out so we're so we're
launching a site called 137 p.m. it's
like complex meets vise meets business
insider meets XXL it's gonna be it's
it's really like my huffington post like
the [ __ ] that I [ __ ] with
entrepreneurship music sports it's
coming out next week there's a series I
want to make called 24 hours width
one of the things I want to do is throw
a curveball even though it's for men to
talk about women that are hustling and
winning too and grinding I think it'd be
really fresh if we legitimately like
what I was losing set like what probably
could be set he's starting to do some
work uh but like babban or Hitler I
don't know but literally silver per 24
hours including when she goes to sleep
we need to sleep on the couch and put
the camera down and it would just be
like looking at her wall and it would
just say 1:00 a.m. to 3 a.m. 4 a.m. 5
a.m. 6 a.m. 7 a.m.
got it could be really cool I think I
can get a lot of eyes on it what about
music Wednesday when what is the next
music what's going on are you gonna drop
a mixtape have you thought about
dropping a song or two randomly yeah I
really believe in a man I can't like I
know I'm you know I'm a broken [ __ ]
record but like I just believe in that
[ __ ] it just it's just Matt like I'll
give you the example for me outsider
paying attention and really wants you to
win
I'm abt needs a [ __ ] summer anthem
please read up
the [ __ ] are you doing when your summer
with your long-ass blonde hair you know
like I want to know you see what I'm
going yeah like I feel like every artist
that's not to come up net like I'm gonna
actually it's my new [ __ ] thing that
I just made it up right now like like
put your [ __ ] out Memorial Day you need
a [ __ ] summer anthem like everybody
should people haven't caught up to the
way distribution works summer anthems
are [ __ ] game changers they're game
changers they're game changers somehow
anthems are game changers put out your
[ __ ] and if you know you're putting
out a summer anthem in March you're
writing you're thinking you're
contemplating and boom like that's
that's what people should be doing
I get listen I get it yeah I get it like
you could just alter it a little you
know just change the hook and it's a
summer anthem you know you know she
produces you right you're a [ __ ]
one-woman shop produces brights sings
does it there was a time when I was
trying to put out video here's what I
would say three things one we're gonna
start chopping up our idea if we want to
come out with sometime Tuesday after
Labor Day as a thing for me I like it
but I got to marinate - I'd love to do
it 24 hours with young baby tape
literally you got to get ready though
like you know if you need you know
you're cute girl so if you want me to
have a female videographer it's 24 hours
then coming to your home but also said
he's harmless
he's harmless for 137 p.m. and that's
very much about entrepreneurship I want
to know about your like you'll film your
day start thinking about the day in the
next two to three weeks got it
got a pointer taking notes if I'm making
a hustle day
load it up but I want people I want men
men 15 to 35 being inspired by how hard
you went got it yeah and then and then
number three just I really think you
should put out a song one off summer
anthem in the next month I will give it
love I'm sure you sit on something sure
you got a contender and even if you have
to like get somebody to join in and give
a hook or a reverse set give it a little
summer flavor and then pour most of all
and this is what I really wanted want to
meet I think you guys already know this
but we are here bat phone bat phone
three days before a show in New York
nobody's going for some reason the
promoter [ __ ] up or it's one of those
things tell us how we can help
no joke we love you I love you I think
you've been stressed thing yeah we must
have the same taste I don't get that
deep like I'm think about the seven
people I've gotten four you've got like
two or three of them it's the taste
thing it makes sense yeah I really think
you got a shot I think you got a place I
think you need to be smart about hacking
culture collaborations putting the
volume you put out things you put out
how you do things but you could perform
your ass off
and that [ __ ] that is a real thing
that plays that's longevity to me yeah
so literally if you had one hit for real
like one true hit like if you were a
one-hit wonder who nobody you kind of
nobody wants to be but it's better than
being a no get wonder you're so great at
performing that you'd be that you would
be coast to coast you'd be able have the
next 40 years of your life that gets me
emotional about you putting out more
music because then I know it's just one
song away how old are you love it let's
take a photo I'm in about
she's got her plap I know your platforms
are on I knew the universe I know how
you go
Boyd got the flash
I love very much thank you we will
continue to support yeah hit me up on
that thread yeah love you I'll see you
[Music]